صهيب بماذا يختلف اليوم الرابع من عمليه
طوفان الاقصى يختلف بان هناك دخول جديد في
سياق التحذيرات والتهديدات
المتبادله تهديد اسرائيلي بتهجير سكان
قطاع غزه وتحذيرات واشارات الاجتياح بري
في المقابل تهديد غير مسبوق للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه هذا اليوم اعطت مهله ساعتين
لسكان عسقلان
باخلاقها والا فانها ستتعرض لضربات كثيفه
لل وبالفعل في تمام الساعه الخامسه من
مساء هذا اليوم اطلقت كتائب القسام دفعه
كبيره جدا من الصواريخ كما قالت الكتائب
بانها وصلت الى المئات وحذرت الكتائب في
تغريداتها بانها ستواصل دك او ما وصفته
بدك مدينه عسقلان حتى تهجير اهلها ال الا
اذا توقف الاحتلال عن سياسه تهجير
المدنيين وقالت الكتاب بانها ستنتقل
لتهجير مدينه اخرى اذا لم يتوقف الاحتلال
عن سياسه التهجير اذا نحن دخلنا في سياق
اخر في هذه المعركه معركه طوفان الاقصى في
اليوم الرابع على التوالي بالاضافه الى
المعارك الم المستمره على الارض في زكين
كان هناك دخول لمسلحين كتائب القسام الى
هناك واشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه قوات الاحتلال
تقول بانها استعاده السيطره على كامل
منطقه غلاف قطاع غزه ولكنها لم تعلن
بالتفصيل بانها فعلا استطاعت او تمكنت من
قتل كل مقاتلي القسام او اعتقالهم على
الاقل في تلك المناطق لتالي المنطقه غلاف
غزه اذا ما تحدثنا عن عمق 4 كيلو متر في
كل محيط غلاف غزه هي منطقه ضبابيه حتى
الان لا لا يمكن لاي طرف من الاطراف ان
يثبت بانه سيسيطر عليها بشكل كامل مع
التكثيف توجيه الضربات الاسرائيليه من
الجو وكثافه الدفع بقوات بريه لاسرائيل
باتجاه محيط قطاع غزه بالاليات الثقيله
اذا نحن امام ساعات ماضيه كانت قويه
وعنيفه للغايه وتحذيرات من ساعات قادمه قد
تكون اكثر قوه واكثر عنفا